merci de nous rejoindre pour ce premier
débat de la saison 7 8 le débat
dorénavant chaque mardi 18h30 pour la
première diffusion le 8 septembre les
enseignants en tout cas une partie
d'entre eux seront donc dans la rue un
appel à la grève lancé par une
intersyndicale qui entend ainsi
protester contre une réforme du collège
censée entrer en vigueur au mois de
septembre en ce mois de septembre la
réforme prévoit de nouveaux programmes
une nouvelle organisation
mais pour la ministre de l'éducation
najat vallaud belkacem la terre ne va
pas se fendre en deux pour autant
dialogue de sourds entre professeurs et
gouvernement et le bras de fer qui se
poursuit en plateau pour en parler
benoît car morale délégué se-unsa 78
bonjour pour soirée puis delphine
romagné bonsoir à vous vous êtes
secrétaire du snes fsu 78 on va
commencer avec soin vous êtes contre
cette réforme expliquez-nous en quelques
mots pourquoi en cette rentrée à côté
des cartables les professeurs ont aussi
des banderoles d'accord si vous pouvez
me permettre je voudrais juste ajouter
une petite précision vos propos c'est
que l'intersyndicale appelle à la grève
contre la forme du collège mais pas
seulement c'est aussi pour une
amélioration des conditions de travail
de tous les personnels une
revalorisation des salaires et des
carrières est aussi une véritable
réforme du lycée une mise à plat de la
réforme chatel
donc ceci étant dit donc on va revenir
au sujet principal forme mais collet
qui va effectivement être notre sujet
principal
donc il ya beaucoup de choses qui ce
qu'ils se sont dit dans les médias sur
la réforme des collèges on a beaucoup
entendu parler de la suppression des
classes européennes de la disparition du
latin bien sûr il ya d'autres choses qui
sont un petit peu plus compliqué à
expliquer et qui ont du coup moins
attiré l'attention médiatique parce que
c'était un message plus difficile à
faire passer c'est l'autonomie de
l'établissement qui les a accordées dans
le cadre de cette réforme puisqu'il faut
savoir qu environ 20% des heures vont
être à la discrétion des équipes
pédagogiques qui vont l'utiliser comme
elles veulent donc par là c'est vrai
aussi que les enseignants puissent
travailler entre eux autour de projets
communs voilà c'est ça et puis il ya ce
fait nous le pays en un enseignement
pratique interdisciplinaire
qui
qui est
ne sont pas une mauvaise chose en soi le
snes me dis pas qu'il ne faut pas
travailler en interdisciplinarité
mais par contre nous avons beaucoup de
réserve et même de critiques à apporter
sur la manière dont ils vont se mettre
en oeuvre
et par concours vous obtenez un moins
bon des quoi pour vous c'est une bonne
chose
honnêtement il faut peut-être remonter
un tout petit peu et savoir pourquoi est
ce que cette réforme est mis en place le
constat il est simple c'est que le
collège ne fonctionne pas correctement
bonsoir on est partisan de l'inaction
soit on essaye de mettre en place un
certain nombre de choses et vous l'avez
dit en reprenant les propos de la
ministre c'est pas forcément une
révolution c'est à dire c'est plutôt
prendre en compte des choses qui
existent déjà les généraliser donné
effectivement des moyens aux
établissements pour qu'ils puissent en
disposer et crée en fait quelque chose
qui améliore les résultats des élèves ça
c'est quelque chose d'important qui leur
permettent d'avoir le bagage nécessaire
pour continuer leurs études ça c'est
aussi quelque chose d'important et je
reviendrai sur autre chose qui me semble
extrêmement important c'est que l'entrée
en sixième c'est quelque chose de
difficile et dans le cadre de la réforme
du collège il y à la création du cycle 3
cm1 cm2 6e pour justement que les élèves
de 6e après nos collèges après nous
convenablement le collège donc il ya
énormément de choses qui sont positifs
maintenant vous l'avais dit la mise en
place est compliqué attendre vous avez
dit qu'elle était censée demi en place
et des mises en place et ça commence bon
il y aura sans doute quelques petites
difficultés mais on voit quand même que
les choses se mettent en place vous avez
parlé d' inter syndicale moi je vois
qu'à moins deux syndicats qui
appartiennent à cette intersyndicale bon
peut-être que ça cathy elle passe à la
future salle est tout à fait mais il y
en a moins sûr on verra ce que ça donne
maintenant il ya une accélération pour
vous ça veut dire quoi que celle de
cette opposition est marginale
finalement j'aimerais y avoir de
position du tout je ne dis pas qu'elle
est marginale jeudi que justement une
réforme ne peut pas se faire sans les
personnels de l'éducation il ya eu des
discussions peut-être qu'il aurait fait
en avoir davantage maintenant les
discussions ont entraîné les compromis
et au bout d'un moment il l'a fallu
préparer en fait cette cette rentrée et
honnêtement dans la plupart des collèges
la rentrée c'est préparer correctement
et ça me paraît en amont elle serait pas
elle s'est préparée en mai jour où donc
la montée ce précieux la grève qui
s'annonce pour la rentrée n'est pas le
légitime pour les manifestations je ne
dirai jamais donc le grève n'est pas
légitime a au contraire bien sûr il faut
sans doute du point de vue des syndicats
qui appellent à la manifestation
exprimer leurs opinions
maintenant les choses se mettent en
place le 9 la réforme va pas s'arrêter
voilà donc être là continue et elle va
s'améliorer y aura sans doute des choses
qui vont pas fonctionné on le verra mais
dire que c'est quelque chose de
totalement les limites il je pense pour
les élèves qui décrochait à la fin de
l'année troisième je pense pour beaucoup
de parents qui se posaient des questions
bah je crois que ça peut améliorer les
choses et encore une fois c'est pas une
réforme qui va améliorer toutes les
choses je ne crois pas mais vous non
plus à une réforme qui améliore
absolument tout finalement vous êtes
d'accord sur quelque chose - delphine
manitobaine a bien écouté votre mot log
pour pour l'unsa 78 on a le sentiment
que cette grève finalement ok il ya une
contestation mais finalement ça pas
grand chose finalement puisque la
réforme va se poursuivrait alors
effectivement la réforme va se mettre en
place alors je voudrais répondre quand
même à mon homologue que il ya quand
même un certain nombre de syndicats qui
appellent à cette grève il ya le synass
bien sûr qu'ils aient le syndicat
majoritaire dans la profession il ya fo
et sud il ya la cgt éducation donc ça
fait quand même un certain nombre de
syndicats qui qui se montre opposé effet
notable dans les mobilisations de
l'année scolaire précédente ils viennent
même des syndicats d'enseignement privé
qui appelait donc ça donne une idée
quand même du point auquel on en est
arrivé de la contestation qui gronde
alors c'est vrai que beaucoup de
collègues
ne sont pas favorables à cette réforme
et sont un petit peu dans l'expectative
je penserai assez rapidement les choses
vont se mettre en place et que ça va
être compliqué mais dans la contestation
du 8a va servir à quoi quel est
l'objectif parce que tout de même vous
demander un moratoire en tout cas votre
syndicat demande un moratoire
actuellement son réforme alors on
demande à un moratoire et je dirais même
plus nos mots d'ordre ç'a toujours été
l'abrogation donc nous ne sommes pas
contre une réforme du collège suis
d'accord avec vous il en faut une le
collège dysfonctionne beaucoup d'élèves
sont en échec par contre ce que nous
demandons c'est une autre réforme une
réforme qui soit élaboré en concertation
avec les personnels
il faut savoir que cette réforme a été
mise en place dans la précipitation que
les programmes vont être renouvelées sur
quatre niveaux en même temps
que dans beaucoup de collèges les
manuels ne sont pas arrivés à temps
donc on va commencer à l'année sont
manuels de français sont manuels
d'histoire géographie
par exemple qu'on prend des exemples qui
parle aux habitants des yvelines au
collège de bréval il manque des manuels
pour deux classes entières
au collège rimbaud d'auberge envie il
manque des manuels en histoire
géographie on maps donc c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est problématique et
qui va rendre le début d'année difficile
benoît kermoal ça vous fait sourire pas
forcément le manque de manuels mais
l'ensemble oui mais je la prends que le
snes et pour la
les deux pays ça me fait plaisir parce
que je pense qu'effectivement s'apprécie
chance de les ôter oui c'est nîmes on
pratique un terme à leur discipline
était en fait tout simplement de moduler
deux enseignements pour des élèves
puissent comprendre en fait plutôt que
de faire des mathématiques d'un côté et
de l'histoire géographie de notre côté
comprendre les ponts qui peut y avoir
entre ça nécessite beaucoup de
réflexions de la part des élèves et on a
constaté qu'en fait lorsqu'il pratiquait
de tel ce pays qui vont qui vont se
concrétiser par des objets c'est à dire
c'est pas c'est pas purement scolaire je
dirais on a constaté que ça leur
permettait justement de réinvestir les
savoir qui était dans chaque discipline
ça c'est quelque chose d'important je
suis aussi content de savoir que le snes
et pour une réforme du collège et encore
une fois mois soit c'est l'inaction vous
avez dit que c'est précipité la réforme
du collège était prévue en 2013 donc il
ya eu trois ans de préparation il ya eu
effectivement des des couacs je pense à
la question des programmes 1 honnêtement
il ya eu des difficultés dans sa maison
et beaucoup de concertation les parents
étaient concertées et encore une fente
en tant que parent on peut se dire
moins d'heures par exemple au collège en
sixième ça peut être intéressant parce
que les les petits collégiens de sixième
étaient fatigués ça c'est quelque chose
d'important qu'on leur donne de la
personnalité personnalisé en 6e 3 heures
sur comment apprendre comment gérer son
sac ne serait-ce que ça
comment gérer son emploi du temps
comment réinvestir ces savoirs etc etc
on a là des pistes qui sont
intéressantes les savoirs sont quand
même là c'est à dire que les disciplines
continuer de transsene yens vous avez
dit disparition du latin mais le latin
va rester en enseignements
complémentaires la timbale est intégré
dans ce qu'on appelle les pays de langue
et culture de l'antiquité
faut quand même savoir que le latin
était pratiquée au collège comme une
distinction 1 et qu'ensuite au lycée il
y avait très peu de chambres qui faisait
du latin mais vous écoutent tous les
deux en fait il ya deux lectures de
cette réforme pour finalement faire il
ya vraiment de la rouille et d'os
l'impression qu'on est face à deux
textes différents
symptômes de choses qui vient d'être dit
alors non le sna ce n'est pas pour les
yeux pays le snes a toujours été
favorable au travail en
interdisciplinarité
vous avez dit encore que vous avez dit
contraire tout salir est pour ça que je
dis ça vous aviez pour les deux pays
alors oui sans doute c'était une
formulation peut-être avoir un précise
de ma part on a toujours été contre les
yeux pays parce qu'ils nous faisons
preuve problème c'est la mise en oeuvre
alors cep il faut savoir qu'ils ont été
les thèmes ont été décidées après
l'écriture des programmes qui sera dans
tous les programmes
on intègre les programmes on intègre les
deux pays dans les programmes y ait des
items donc faut pas dire ça
et oui nous ce qui nous dérange aussi
c'était sont retranchés des horaires
disciplinaires donc ça veut dire que je
professeur de français qui à 3h ou 4h
avec une classe s'est fait une heure
deux pays manif est autre chose sera
intégrée dans les programmes c'était
programme le pays c'est des programmes
c'est c'est pas c'est pas contre les
programmes c'est justement
interdisciplinaire je suis désolé c'est
différent oui assurent ainsi leur emploi
s'est rendu le travail et qu'on présente
comme intéressant dit les systèmes sont
fatigués c'est pas la joie n'a cessé
quelques heures dans une semaine c'est
très peu d'heures si c'était la panique
après 20 heures sur les systèmes sont
fatigués mais les 6e on voit nous des
retours dans les yvelines oui soins 29
30 par classe 26 l'idée de dédoublement
que va permettre cette réforme par
exemple par un car moi l on a bien
compris vous été convaincu de belfin
romani parlons bien d autres chaque
classe va avoir un dédoublement hauteur
de 2h45 avec ses dédoublements il faut
faire de l'accompagnement personnalisé
des deux pays il faut financer un
enseignement de type langues et cultures
de l'antiquité si l'établissement a
choisi de le conserver ce qui n'est pas
obligatoire il faut éventuellement
doubler les langues vivantes personne ne
dira que ce n'est pas important il faut
des doublés en sciences et de la vie et
de la terre et en sciences physiques
pour faire des tp donc on voit bien que
les 2h45 sont nettement insuffisantes et
que donc ça veut dire que dans certains
établissements les élèves vont faire
happer à 29 ou à 30 une question tout de
même cette mobilisation de 8 elle sera
suivie d'autres actions s'est d'ores et
déjà acté ou pas parce qu'on l'a bien
compris il ya deux visions de lecture
est aussi parmi les enseignants que vous
représentez vous allez poursuivre déjà
la mobilisation ça dépendra de l'ampleur
de la mobilisation du mic alors sans
doute la nature des actions qui vont
être proposées évidemment va dépendre de
l'ampleur
donc ce qui se passe au niveau du snes
versailles c'est que nous on va proposer
un plan d'action tout au long du mois de
septembre et du mois d'octobre
proposer des réunions éventuellement
avec les fédérations de parents d'élèves
des assemblées générales dans les
établissements scolaires des stages de
formation sur la réforme du collège à
destination des enseignants pour
continuer effectivement une battre
contre cette réforme dont nous
souhaitons l'abrogation parce que vous
allez la défendre cette réforme alors il
est évident d'une part effectivement que
le syndicat des enseignants unsa est
plutôt en faveur de cette réforme bien
conscient aussi des difficultés mais je
crois que tout le monde en est conscient
et l'intérêt c'est de voir comment
est-ce que ça va se pratiquer pour le
moment honnêtement il ya quelques
collèges où il ya des refus où il ya des
couacs etc mais on constate globalement
que les gens s'y sont mis je ne dis pas
que tout vrai faire en un jour en une
année à ce que ça se met en place et
qu'on fasse une évaluation
qu'il y aura des évaluations l'année
dernière j'ai déjà une dévaluation dans
différentes académies c'est à dire qu'il
ya des expérimentations qui ont montré
comment ça fonctionnait il y aura sans
doute aussi des programmes qui vont être
allégée parce qu on se rendra compte que
c'est difficile et puis voilà donc il y
aura des choses qui vont fonctionner on
ne le sera que dans quelques années donc
merci au revoir merci à vous d'être venu
présenter vos arguments en tailleur ou
contre cette réforme des collèges c'est
la fin de ce premier set 8 le débat et
puis bien sûr vous l'avez entendu il y
aura cette grève annoncée au le 8 nous y
reviendrons dans nos éditions du journal
au quotidien cette émission 7,8 débat
est à revoir comme toutes les autres sur
notre site internet et puis a commenté
bien sûr sur les réseaux sociaux